hi I'm a Carmichael welcome to another
edition of Molly the Masters I believe
that the fastest and most effective way
to grow a business is the model the
strategies of people who've already done
it what you're trying to do now today's
boss is brought to you by the AMEX from
business canada facebook page a great
users for entrepreneurs if you want to
check it out and today we can look at
how a farm board from Wales move to
Canada got to start up on for $4,000 and
turned it into almost two billion
dollars this is a story of Terry
Matthews in the top real essence and you
can learn from his success Terry
Matthews is born on June 6 1944 and
wells where we spent a lot of his
childhood as a boy matters would enjoy
taking cars apart and building small
electric motors with the pieces he was
curious to see how much he could put
together on his own
when he found the four-leaf clover in
the field behind a local chapel Matthews
says he knew he was going to be lucky in
life alongside business partner and
fellow British expatriate Copeland math
has borrowed four thousand dollars and
founded advanced networking devices he
had no business - speak of popes
convinced he had an idea worth putting
on the market the pair also wanted to
raise seed money for future enterprises
they were planning six months later he
changed his name to Mitel while some
believe Mike Bell stands for Mike and
Terry's electric lawnmowers after their
first failed product Copeland insists
his stands for Mike and Terry
electronics acknowledging that importing
lawnmowers was not going to be his
ticket to success Matthews shifted
Mitel's focus with the introduction of
the touch-tone receiver as well as a PBX
call routing system Mike Hill
revolutionized a telecommunication
industry now as a British Knight as well
as a billionaire Matthews continues to
serve as founder and chairman of Wesley
clover an investment firm with
investments in telecommunications real
estate and leisure as well as being
directly involved in a handful of other
companies all focused on next-generation
technologies that Matthews believes will
give him his next
big success by following his passion am
I not giving up at the first sign of
failure Terry Matthews was able to go
from having to borrow $4,000 to start up
a business into becoming a billionaire
to help grow your business
here are three auction items that you
can learn from Terry Matthews auction
item number one be persistent if there
were rules of entrepreneurship being
persistent would be close to the top of
the list being an entrepreneur is tough
the people will reject you you're run
short of money you leave in wonder if
you're better to just give up and go get
a nine-to-five job if you have a passion
for what you do and you're providing a
valuable service or product to your
customers you have to keep going remind
yourself why you started your business
and hold on to the image of you being
the successful entrepreneur that you
want to be it's a long tough road but
it's totally worth it be persistent and
keep going
Matthews career has largely been
characterized by two things is for
sensitive and active involvement in all
of his companies and his thorough
knowledge of the industry in which is
involved Matthew started 80 different
companies and has an excellent track
record of success he is a hands-on
investor and persistent when it comes to
business when he first started out he
discovered when you leave things to
other people you stand a better chance
of losing money
I've been persistent you can keep
reminding others that you have a good
idea but being hands-on you will not be
a passive investor and will know
everything about the business being able
to solve challenges as they come up
according to Matthews I don't think I'm
stubborn I just focus on the task at
hand and do what it takes persistence is
the single most important thing for
success our shipment of mowers was lost
at sea and while we waited winter
descended and covered our green lawns
with snow that taught me a key lesson
the importance of timing the shipped
company lost the lawnmowers by the time
they showed up no one wanted them as you
can't cut grass when it's covered with
snow
action and number to build relationships
you can't start a business in isolation
to be successful you need to develop
relationships with potential customers
investors media suppliers employees and
the list goes on
listen to people and help them get with
day one you normally get the
satisfaction of doing good deeds they'll
also come back to help you when you most
need it as a young boy growing up in
Wales Matthews was a born engineer he
loved to fix anything that was broken
and break something even if it was not
just for the fun of putting it back
together again if anyone in town had
electric motor the needed repairing
roving the music box and needed a second
life they knew where to turn but it was
not just his engineering skills that
were being developed at the time
Matthews is learning crucial people on
relationship skills that would come in
handy years later that is why he truly
believes that business success depends
on teamwork and relationships with
others according to Matthews I always
had engineering in my blood and a got a
reputation for being able to fix stuff
and when people asked how much I'd
always say it's a pleasure and no charge
I left an obligation and I very quickly
found when christmas came around I had
so many gifts but there is a payment
it's a settled account but if it's for
free
it is not settled and it engenders a
very close relationship I helped to
build my tell and the new bridge and
lots of other companies developing a
tight team relationship and a fighting
spirit that wins I love kicking ass
action item number three make the
product beneficial the amount of money
that you make will grow according to how
much value you're giving your clients if
you're helping solve a major problem for
them and you're providing outstanding
value you can charge more money if
you're an average company sell an
average product don't expect to get
outstanding results keep focused on your
customer and give them the most value
you can think of and they'll reward you
with money in your pocket the bottom
line for Matthews is developing a
product that will in turn deliver real
benefits to his clients under Matthews
leadership
Mitel introduced a product called your
assistant which won accolades across the
board precisely because of its unique
added value
demonstrating valued clients is one of
the biggest challenges companies face
Matthews has reached new heights of
success because he has not just pushed
new technologies he's created products
that opened new opportunities and
offered added value to companies by
focusing on the end results he's been
able to stay at the forefront of the
industry and always one step ahead of
the rest according to Matthews to start
you're not looking at the replacement of
simple things so for example if I said
to a businessperson I have really good
news I'm speaking to you through a voice
over IP system well big deal I can do
that over traditional phones to the
network every different vertical has its
own set of killer apps but the important
thing is that IP broadband has created a
killer environment for new apps during
2004 the conditions that would allow
getting killer apps were there but the
confusion as to how to get there and
what they could gain was not present
companies want to see benefits in a
substantive way anything you can
introduce that one speaks to revenue
growth and to reduces costs and improve
customer satisfaction that's all good
so remember be persistent build
relationships and make your product
beneficial to finish up this video I
wanted to share with my favorite true
stories of Elle teri Matthews and some
of his best quotes a 1980 Terry Matthews
purchased a derelict nineteenth-century
manor house in Wales the biggest reason
he purchased the house was because he
saw the potential to the community and
believed to have benefit the locals as
well as Wales one thing that was left
out of this reason is that Malthus had
been born in manor house when it was a
hospital it did not like seeing a place
that was person important to him get
torn down instead Matthews invested 125
million dollars in revitalizing the
manor house it was a commercial venture
and more importantly it was a place that
Matthews found to be a part of his past
superb countryside and his placement
close to a major highway was a good area
to start some local businesses it is now
the Celtic Manor Resort that brings in
millions of dollars to the community and
provides hundreds of jobs to the locals
according to Matthews I think the resort
can act as a magnet to draw a new
investment into Wales from across UK and
overseas I did my best to put up a
building that you can see from the West
End of London and I didn't come far
short of it
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling the masters if you
liked the video and you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below I'd
also love to hear your comments if you
want to leave one underneath the video
or if you have a question so thank you
and again this post is brought to you by
the American Business Canada Facebook
page every users for entrepreneurs I
hope will go check it out and join the
conversation
see you soon
you